hang on guys
we're this is the only time i get to be
on camera and actually speak so
let me have my moment here
did y'all feel that because i got flaps
oh good i'm live hi everybody welcome to
binge battle mpu edition boy
we've had a lot of great pinch battles
and that's all thanks to all the fans
watching us across
numerous platforms here today everything
from fandango to fandago all access
movies.com the rotten tomatoes youtube
page and
right here on the rotten tomatoes
facebook page it's facebook where you
can actually determine the winner of
today's binge battle we're gonna go
round by round
it's a team tournament today tag team
team fandango versus team rotten
tomatoes you're gonna be voting with
your hearts and
with your thumbs that is likes and that
is loves if you think
team fandango got the win in any
particular round then you're going to
click that love button you're going to
click that hard
if you think that rotten tomatoes got
the better
team fandango in a particular round then
you are going to hit that thumbs up
that like button yes it is like versus
love but we love
everybody equally here at rotten
tomatoes my name is mark ellis and i'm
thrilled to be hosting this
because this is the biggest one we've
ever done and why not do it on the mcu
the biggest
movie franchise i think box office wise
in the history
of time and it doesn't matter if you
have half the world out of existence
they're all still going to line up to go
see
every mc movie that comes out we're
going to be talking about everything
mcu all the way back to 2008. was it
really 12 years ago molly who's asleep
you can't do it
i think it won let's
introduce today's combatants starting
out
for team rotten tomatoes she is much
more than just a kid from broken
although she currently resides in
brooklyn just like captain america's old
stomping of grounds
she's the one the only the blurred girl
caramel horn
caramel how are we i'm good how are you
i'm feeling i'm feeling good about this
battle i had a really good time last
time so
and i'm excited because i'm back now
with a teammate
i'm feeling good you got the win last
time when we were talking about avatar
the last airbender now joining you for
this mcu
combat edition is she is an editor at
rotten tomatoes she's one of my very
best friends she is
jacqueline coley jacqueline do you have
your dog
on set he is on set but he is scared
about all the sounds he's already heard
he's hiding out in his little bed
it's strange for him he doesn't
understand what's going on it's about to
get worse too
so i don't blame him but i'm very glad
to be
here you might as well put me and your
dog in the same corner because we're
just hanging on
by the feet of our pants as we introduce
the opposing team that would be team
fandango and they are led by someone who
i believe has every corner of his wall
and possibly his ceiling covered
in comic book paraphernalia that is a
hilarious stand-up comedian you know him
you love him mr j
washington chicago oh
really really
look the two of y'all would say i'm
extra but i figured since we do an mcu
battle why not the dude who hosts the
man titan podcast just have an infinity
gauntlet
because we know we gonna win thank you
so much for having me mark you're such a
wonderful host
if there is one thing you can ride
washington to do it's to sneak that mad
titan podcast plug it in there
as he as he's ready with his infinity
gauntlet
joining the eric davis from fandango is
here as well eric i know you're
currently in new york too
uh did you bring uh powerglove freddy
krueger's glove anything that you can
i have i i have my infinity gauntlet
right here
i got it the team to beat
is on the table right now and then i got
my girl right here representing black
widow
coming soon and we're very very
impressive representation so look
fandango
versus team rotten tomatoes team ryan
tomaz i know y'all are experts in this
stuff but you are going against
a nerd i see this i see this
we are going against doing the most
that's what i'm saying you know what i
don't agree with it
i'm going to let them make this decision
we don't need gimmicks we got facts
all right team fandango you're uh your
last salvo eric
uh what do you got for team rotten
tomatoes in store for today
uh we got a lot we got a lot going on um
we're going to debate and uh we're gonna
bring it we're gonna bring the gauntlets
the gauntlets and uh we're gonna have a
good time
all right welcome really excited to be
here but either way
we're gonna get going underway in round
number one what is the round queue it up
it is the best origin story in the
history
of the mcu so the way that we do the tag
team here is that the team is going to
have to decide which combatant
is going to be representing their squad
in round
number one it's only one teammate
debating in round number one then the
opposite teammate will debate whatever
the question is
in round at number two so team rotten
tomatoes
who wants to go first is it gonna be
caramel or is it gonna be jacqueline
talking about the best origin story
i'll take it i'll take this one all
right i like the confidence
here's how it's gonna work in round
number one a minute is gonna be on the
clock and i have a fancy
boxing belt that i'm gonna ding when
that minute is up is anybody gonna
respect it
probably not but hey i need to do my job
as best i can so camera's gonna have a
minute and then team fandango it looks
like it's probably gonna be eric davis
going first
round number one is that right eric it
is going to be me i'm taking this one
all right eric goes origin and we're
about ready to go
eric you're going to have a minute after
caramel and then caramel you're going to
have a quick rebuttal it's going to be
about 10 seconds
and then we're going to go to eric for
his rebuttal and then that is going to
be the round
and then we leave it up to you once
again folks everybody watching us right
now
on facebook you are in charge of who
wins each round you click those thumbs
up
that's the like button if you think team
rotten tomatoes had the better argument
you click that heart that's the love
button if you think team fandango did a
little bit better so
thumbs up for rotten tomatoes hearts for
fandango
and without further ado you're kicking
us off
in round number one okay i have to say
that i think in all the mcu the best
origin story the best arc belongs to
tony stark
now he started off as a genius
billionaire billionaire playboy
arms dealer but he ended the first movie
by saying i am iron man out of hubris
but he goes from selfish
to selfless he used scrap metal to build
a new suit he goes after the people who
stole his tech
his mindset was changed he went from
knowing he was the smartest person in
the room
to collaborating with people like banner
on the avengers
he also created the second family that
he didn't
think he really had he never really had
a family grew up
really alone and being a genius he kind
of felt he was
always by himself the avengers were his
family and then he starts creating
inventions
for the team he's got rhodey's suit he
fixed cap's shield
he's got jarvis who then turns into
vision
but it all took a toll we also saw his
arc go up and down he suffered from ptsd
we saw that in iron man 3.
this was the most human arc that we've
seen in really in a superhero movie
ever and then basically after going into
space
he almost he took another toll so
by the end of this at the end of end
game iron man is not
selfish anymore he's selfless and that
is why when he says i'm iron man again
oh there's a bell
argument and you kind of wrap it up
they're nice i didn't think that you'd
be able to get from iron man all the way
to end game
in one minute but that was a very
impressive history lesson and that's a
tough argument for eric to counter so
eric you're going up against tony stark
and
iron man what is the best origin story
in the mcu
one minute on the clock sir the best
origin story in the mcu is captain
america
and it is captain america the first
avenger for three reasons
the setting the spectacle and it's
sentimental
the setting early 40s it's a throwback
it's the only period piece in the mcu
which opens it up to all of these really
great action sequences that we don't see
in other movies
like the foot chase through the streets
of brooklyn which is my personal
favorite
spectacle you know there's all kinds of
really great action sequences but also
the special effects in that film
were groundbreaking it was really the
only the first time that marvel studios
was using those effects
to make skinny steve rogers and then
hunky steve rogers
and those special effects went on to
become a staple in the mcu movies
uh when it came to de-aging characters
and whatnot uh the
effects on red skull were really cool
and just the the adventising of that
movie was fantastic and then it's
sentimental
you know you have his best friend bucky
and you have their journey
you have his love the love of his life
in peggy
and what i love about what i love about
captain america is at the end of that
film
he is down he has lost his best friend
he has lost the love of his life
he is now trapped in a time that he is
not familiar he
does not know that and it sets up what i
think are the two most superior sequels
that we have ever seen in the mcu forget
about iron man 2 and iron man 3 i'm
throwing those in the garbage
captain america the winter soldier
captain america civil war
are fantastic sequels and it is because
that ending
of that origin story that's
it and under the wire with the love for
not only captain america the first
avenger but also
the two incredible sequels that it's
really gonna be up to the fans
that might be the crux of the decision
for a lot of people watching right now
is
okay well do i consider those two
captain america sequels captain america
movies are they more like avengers light
and then you have iron man two and three
sure but we're talking origin story iron
man versus captain america
it's quite a battle folks so get those
final votes in
right now hit that thumbs up if you
think caramel and iron man are the
better origin story hit that heart
button
if you think eric and captain america
should take the cake today so camera
we're going to pivot back to you
quick 10 to 15 second closer for your
argument in round number one
captain america has an amazing origin
story but
he had he plays one note he's always the
boy scout
when we're talking about a development
of a character an origin story we gotta
talk about how
where they get to tony gets to a change
he
becomes a selfless person also
sentimental
come on i love you three thousand what
quotes does captain america have
language come on
funny though but yeah the i love you
three 000 is something that uh
the muppet hears from time to time so
eric pretty strong
clothes there but was it a mic dropping
about to find out
the first of all what could be kind of
art this is a man that was
that was all about serving his country
he is taken to another time period
he has to learn the world all over again
and then he has to betray the government
that he has always fought for
in order to stand up for what he
believes is right and what he believes
in
uh and then he has to you know defend
his fight his other best friend
and then he has to go and save the world
and hold for his hammer
and crush it all captain america is the
man all right
that is gonna do it for round number one
two very spirited arguments kicking us
off here in round number one for best
origin story
i love these comments so far oddly
enough
i'm seeing a lot of love for thor on the
comment section for a lot of people
well thor's origin story uh caleb pace
has a great comment caleb says tony's
very smart but his dad built his empire
and money captain america
is the best origin through his entire
journey we're there we're there caleb
but then you also like your opinion man
[Laughter]
let's see maria gone says iron man was
the base for
many movies if the origin story wasn't
good there would be no mcu so
two pretty great arguments here and now
it's going to be all up to the fans
to decide if it is karama representing
iron man or if it is eric davis
representing captain america before i
give the final tally uh
jacqueline how would you say your
teammate fared in round number one
run us our thumbs up run them cause like
she murdered it she talked about it and
she talked about a real arc
i love captain america he is the heart
of the avengers
but tony's the head and he had to work
through so many things captain is the
same i can do this all day
literally from the beginning and the end
okay jay final word goes to you why
should everybody vote for your teammate
eric davis
because he has america's ass
[Music]
we don't need to know why jay has his
information but
he does and correct information that's
correct
america's ass has just gone up one
nothing over rotten tomatoes
did win and now team fandango's up one
nothing over team rotten tomatoes rotten
tomatoes finding himself in an
unfamiliar position
trailing to anybody much less fandango
against eric davis and jay washington so
now
we move on to round number two this one
is going to be jay washington versus
jacqueline
coley and jake you're going to be going
come on jackie work it out
they're going to have about a minute and
once that minute hits i'm going to hit
that boxing bill that means your time is
up and the question
oh boy this this could get very very
competitive because it is the most
iconic moment
in the mcu jay washington one minute
starts now going off my part of using
captain america's best origin story the
best moment within the entire mcu
is avengers assemble the reason being
we have waited almost 10 years to
finally hear that line
we never heard it in the first movie at
the end of the second
second avengers movie we heard avengers
cut off we thought we were finally gonna
hear it
we had a build up into this giant
climactic scene
something like a marvel poster you would
have in your room
to finally see cap wielding a broken
shield and milnor in his hands
and saying a symbol and watching
theaters across the world
go crazy there was no other moment i am
iron man
did it because it had its emotions but
avengers assemble everybody had been
waiting on that particular moment
there you go all right so i am iron man
and we get the avengers assemble we got
all that sort of good stuff
and it does take us on a journey through
virtually the entire
mcu so very good round for jay not just
because i didn't have to ding the bell
but also because he made a good point so
jacqueline coley if you want the folks
out there to hit the thumbs up for your
team instead of the hearts for j
what do you got okay when we're gonna
talk about the most iconic moment in the
mcu
we really have to talk about what jay
said but it's not his moment what we've
been leading up to
what we've really been leading up to for
everybody that was talking about how
much they love captain america
when he picks up mjolnir that is the
most iconic moment
not only does it pay off something that
they set up going back to
when we first introduced thor saying his
hammer makes him feel like you are
worthy
it is teased in avengers age of ultron
and when
cap picks that up after being beaten
down by thanos and you know that thor
is maybe going to die if he doesn't get
mjolnir and come and attack him
it says so much about the heart of the
avengers
shows who he is he gets that hammer and
just
pounds into thanos and then thor just
comes back and says i knew it
that to me is the jump up in the middle
of your seat moment in the theater
avengers assemble is amazing but let's
be honest it's a tagline
this is an actual moment this is
something that you're talking about to
your friends
this is when they say don't spoil it
this is what they say
don't tell me about that moment because
you want to feel that moment
for the very first time from when you
see it just pull up slightly
until when you see it come right down on
thanos's head
i just want to hit it anyway you were
pretty much right at a minute so jaclyn
wins the
not running the light by the closest
margin award
[Laughter]
so jacqueline uh you have a moment jay
has a moment that's now on the table so
now it's up to everybody watching us
on facebook to decide which argument
they think was better if you think team
fandango represented by jay washington
had the better argument then you hit
that heart button that's the love button
if you hit the like button the thumbs up
button that is going to give a vote to
jacqueline coley
and team rotten tomatoes but first jay
washington you're going to have about 10
15 seconds if you have any more mic drop
moments or you want to reference another
part of your
co-pilot's anatomy have at it well as
far
as the picking up of milner it only
happened in avengers age of ultron
but we've been waiting for avengers
assemble since the beginning
of formation of the avengers together we
got teased it yes it was a great moment
to see him will milnor
but to know you finally heard the
tagline yes
every mcu movie has a great tag line
whether it's ibom bay
or you know i am iron man all these
movies have it but avengers assemble is
what this entire infiniti saga has
become
and it's what it's about and it does not
make sense to culminate it without the
words of israel's assembly
the avengers certainly have assembled
and now they're on two different teams
so this feels a little bit more like
captain america civil war so jacqueline
continue the battle
your final word on the best moment
in the mcu i'm confused is the question
the best tagline a question is the best
moment when you walked out of end game
you are not running up to your friends
in the lobby
talking about avengers assemble it was
cool but i guarantee you i bet it on my
mama that you were talking about captain
having that
shield and that hammer in his hand that
is what you were talking about
that is the moment that you have in your
mind that's why we call it a
moment and that moment again it doesn't
it's not the longest moment of payoff
it's the best moment of payoff
okay mama that's how we know we get
serious around here oh my god
[Laughter]
cap when i say i could do this all day
but unfortunately uh
the tech crew cannot so we are gonna
call the argument there and while i wait
for the judges to tabulate the votes and
then get that information
in between my ears uh eric davis your
name came up a few times
uh have you been energized by jay
washington's argument do you agree with
your
teammate yeah i mean without a doubt i i
you have a moment that has every single
character from all of the films
going against all of the like the giant
thanos in his army
and you have them all running to each
other i mean it is literally the moment
that we have been waiting for for 20
some odd
films you know i think yeah cap holding
the hammer was cool
avengers age of ultron that's when your
moments quote unquote started
asking innocent questions here caramel
let me get you in here real quick and
you tell me
how much do you stand your teammate
jacqueline coley right now no i'm behind
her 100
because even when you're going across
twitter and you're looking at replays of
gifts from
the from the movie itself though like
the number one thing that people always
play and you hear people screaming
in the theater is when cap
grabs that hammer yes it was amazing to
see everybody
run but as some avengers assemble yes if
you're a kid and you remember the
animated series in the comics and stuff
perfect but this that moment when he got
that hammer that was for
all fans that wasn't just for comic book
fans that's right
and a lot of people in the chat agreeing
with you karama and by proxy with
jacqueline team rotten tomatoes uh anna
christina weighs in and says the theater
shaped
when he got that hammer and then
anthony alicia says uh that it is that
hammer that is the real hero
of the mcu uh jennifer coronado healey
is going with the avengers assemble so
and then brian chimes in and says brian
says i've never seen one of these movies
so thank you for wanking brian
thanks for watching brian so jay you
gave a great argument for avengers
assemble jacqueline you did just as
admirably
for your moment and we're tied up folks
team rotten tomatoes gets the point in
the last seconds and jacqueline coley
has gotten her team
back even with team fandango and that
can only mean one thing
now we move on to round number three
which is going to be our first
tag team round so here is how it
gonna work we got one and a half minutes
for
each team which means 45 seconds for
each participant
the question in round number three is
who is the strongest avenger so
team rod tomatoes is going to be going
first and here's how it works whoever
wants to go first for team rotten
tomatoes may start you have 45 seconds
once you hear that
bell you got to pass the baton over to
your teammate who's going to pick up the
slack
continue the argument and then we will
be finished with your round
we go over to the team fandango for
their rebuttal
and then each team is going to have
about 20 seconds to close out with their
arguments sound good
here we go all right team rotten
tomatoes who wants to go first for the
strongest
universe yeah yeah okay i'll go first
okay like you go
you go you're gonna do the best the best
the best setup i feel
you got anchor i got it's cool no all
right get out of camera
what about started uh i think the
strongest avenger is hulk
basically in terms of the avengers in
the mcu
he had the ability to punch a chitari he
beat the crap out of both thor and
loki he everyone was terrified of him
but they really want him to be on their
side
also hulk is also a banner you've got
one of the smartest minds in the in the
avengers
and even after he left the avengers for
a bit he was a gladiator on
the car the only one who could kick his
ass was thanos
i'm sticking with hulk
and i'm gonna tap up jack i'm gonna go
ahead and tell you captain america is
the captain of captain
marvel is a photon she saved tony stark
in the middle of space without her we
wouldn't have even
had end game she is so powerful she can
literally destroy an entire planet with
all of the energy that she has inside
of us we have to go ahead and say that
captain marvel is the most powerful
avenger and there's not a single person
on this list that she could not destroy
and again
we wouldn't even have the avengers that
we have today if it wasn't for the fact
that she came
and saved the day she was the one that
nick fury calls
just gonna go ahead and put it like that
when you really need an avenger to come
through because nick fury was on the
verge of saying a swear word before he
disappeared into dust but not
before he got that call in to captain
marvel so jay i know you can appreciate
this reference because i feel like i'm
watching an old school wrestling match
where
wow i'm watching my favorite team
arguably
go smack another one of my favorite
teams and y'all were down on the mat i
mean hulk and captain marvel
that's a lot to deal with but i have a
feeling team fandango is going to get up
off the mat here in just a sec
so jay eric 45 seconds who wants to take
it first eric you want it or do you want
me to take it you take it you take it
all right you gotta back you up okay you
got my time started the show
avenger does not even have a regular
name yet it's wanda maximoff you will
come to know as the scarlet witch
why do i say that her powers came from
the tesseract first and foremost
in this mcu realm that we're doing she
can control her mind
and not only is the strongest adventure
because of what she does especially in
in-game when she rips off thanos armor
after he says she tells him you took
everything from me and he says i don't
even know you
we can go into infinity war where she
proves she was the strongest avenger why
because she had to hold back thanos
while also killing the love of her life
and destroying an infinity stone at the
exact same time
if that ain't the strongest avenger no
matter what i don't know who
is all right eric davis europe
look my the strongest avenger for me
it's black widow
because strength isn't just physical
physical ability it's not just getting
into an
accident with gamma radiation or getting
into an accident with a tesseract
it comes from your mind it comes from
your heart and in the case of black
widow
strength comes from your soul you know
she is wicked smart
yeah she can kick ass and take names
she's got tremendous physical ability
she is an assassin a trained assassin
but she also has the strength to
overcome a past of abuse
and she fights through that and she
decides to to take everything that she
learned and everything that she was
raised to and
throw it away in order to join shield
and do the right thing and then when
everything is on the line this woman
she gives up the total sacrifice she
gives up her life
so that her best friend can continue to
have a life
with his family that is strength right
there
black widow all right so black widow and
wanda maximo that would be scarlet witch
are the two combatants that are going to
be put out there on the field
real quick before you go further i would
not i do not appreciate jacqueline
coley's remarks about her face
as soon as eric said black widow
jacqueline was like
hey okay well jacqueline you get a
chance to rebut right now before you do
so i'm just gonna remind all the fans
out there watching us on facebook that
you're voting right now and you're
voting for the fate of our team so
hit that like button that's the thumbs
up button if you like team
rotten tomatoes a little bit better if
you think that
team fandango's got this argument in the
bag then hit that heart button that's
the love button so
jack when you did make a face i don't
know if that's where you want to start
your rebuttal but
here we go about 10 seconds and then
we'll pick up caramel
i will admit that the best thing that
black widow could do is for a minute she
was the only one that could sort of
control the hulk but
i'm sorry like to spoil it for y'all but
by the end hulk can control himself so
literally the best thing she was kind of
doing as far as a power situation
was that look black widow is definitely
a badass i'm not gonna deny that
i have a photon the girl pushes things
through space
that is the strongest avenger without a
doubt and if we're really looking at the
team
i'm just saying if you were going to
have a team and it's scarlet witch and
black widow
or captain marvel and the hulk we know
how this is going down
we know how this is going now
15 seconds is all yours so i'm gonna say
for eric i'm sorry yes black widow gave
her life but that's
why she's no longer couldn't be the
strongest avenger she's dead
she's not coming back waiting for a
movie to come out she's gone she's not
in the mcu
so in terms of hulk he's unkillable he's
literally unkillable and
as far as the comment about wanda i'm
i'm telling you jay if we were talking
about comics i would be right there with
you
this is not house of m she's not been
put she's not been possessed by kathan
i'm sorry she's not
she's weird and he's fast come on y'all
come on no
no okay i don't i what mark why is
strength
it's so one dimension their argument is
so one dimensional it's
just powers i'm sorry i didn't trip and
fall over some gamma radiation
and i'm sorry i didn't get into an
accident with the tesseract
the sun's getting real no big fella
sun's getting real long
actually instead of the tesseract
but i'm sorry captain marvel also
absorbed the tesseract you kind of
forgot that in captain america
okay okay there you go you all can close
out you i'm going to get
the hulk is unstable if it benefits the
hulk
unstable way are you saying one
is less unstable more unstable than the
mark
you got it you gotta let team fandango
finish their argument
right you could let me finish this live
thank you ma'am
unstable look the hulk is unstable the
reason being
the banner had to finally learn to
control him and matter of fact he
couldn't even control him after he got
whooped by thanos
he tried to get him to keep coming out
and the hulk was like
oh don't want to do it all right
there's your strength here's your
strength right there the guy doesn't
even he doesn't even know who he is or
how to control what he is
he doesn't even know strength is from
here so put those hearts on the board
because strength is from your heart
accident with gamma radiation that's
right
we've heard the arguments i think we can
all agree that real strength
is the host being in the middle that's
trying to
[Laughter]
you know you really are the strongest
avenger right now mark we can all
agree democracy you all know right now i
feel like the scene in civil war i think
where captain america is trying to hold
on to the helicopter
but hey we're keeping this thing afloat
and
you all have any more buttons to push go
ahead and do it right now you're
clicking that like button the thumbs up
for a team
rotten tomatoes you're clicking the
heart that's the love button for team
fandango
i i love the arguments i love the
passion i love
the frivolity that we brought i think my
favorite mic drop moment in this round
was probably caramel when she just
simply reminded us the black widow's
dead
thank you for that
a black widow technically is a title
because it's going to be passed on to
elaina bolivar
now we want to keep going all right all
right so i'm looking at the
comments and uh chuck is really really
supporting scarlet witch
so chuck i i think chuck is a little
torn between scarlet witch and
hulk being made from gamma rays and then
joel weighs in and says that
he's not thrilled with fandango right
now the fandango argument's a little
weak and so we'll see
the votes are in they've been tabulated
and it does appear that despite
commenter joel's opinion team fandango
gets the point
there it is
hey literally y'all black widow over a
photon
seriously though i appreciate it you
gotta kill them
you gotta kill the love of your life
while holding back the greatest threat
the universe has ever seen and
destroying one of the most powerful
things the universe has ever known
at the same time you already won all
right
round number four is gonna get a little
spicier round number four it is gonna be
kicked off
by team fandango who now enjoys a
two-to-one win and
no pressure but team fandango can win
the match
with this round if they get the point if
ron tomatoes gets the point we will go
to a tiebreaker round
number five so the question and i love
that i get to qualify this because i
just asked you all who's the strongest
avenger
hero character what have you in round
number four
team fandango mid 30s on the board
because you have to give me
the strongest villain not named
thanos because that'd be too easy so
minute and a half on the board who puts
the 45 seconds first for team fandango
uh i think i'm gonna take it because our
pairing uh sort of matches each other so
uh in the timeline i will take it first
have at it it's all yours eric davis
kicking us off in round four
all right so i think the best villain in
the entire mcu that is not thanos is
zemo from captain america civil war and
what i love so much about zemo is that
he's
unassuming he's unexpected he is the
most unassuming and surprising villain
in the mcu he exacts revenge not by
using his muscle
but by using his brains he turns the
avengers against each other
uh this is one of uh a bunch of setups
that age of ultron laid down
that are paid off after age of ultron
you know it the only epic
finale battle that doesn't include a
fight between the heroes
and the villains this is heroes against
heroes and that final fight
between cap and iron man and bucky in
civil wars without a doubt
the most exhilarating yet heartbreaking
fight that we've ever seen in the mcu
zemo is the most maniacal of all the
villains uh and while he doesn't have
the most badass weapons or army
it made us care the most about these
characters more than we ever realized
we cared about them
zemo pairs nicely with your pick zemo
pairs nicely with the pick
of one indiaca aka killmonger why
because just as unassuming as zemo was
killmonger as well
he managed to overthrow the throne of
wakanda
by beating in ritual combat the king
who again without the strength of
everything supposed to be able to fight
in the adversary
he tricked everybody and he actually
killed the man who was trying to help
him who was just as big of a threat
to wakanda as killmonger is in ulysses
claw not to mention killmonger's plan
was to liberate an entire race of people
all over the world
using all of the weapons in which
wakanda had if
t'challa did not go to umbaku and the
jabari
killmonger would still be running
wakanda right now it took
help to take that man from the throne
and because of his power on the throne
he also assumed control of the dora
melange
personally right on time jay just like
the great comic that you are respecting
the light so we have eric and jay
teaming up
for team fandango and those are some
pretty strong picks so you got zemo and
you got killmonger
they certainly left in a some sort of
semblance of an appearance on a lot of
people now we move on
to rotten tomatoes jacqueline karama who
wants to take it first
i got this one all right listen we're
going to go ahead and talk about the
best villain it has to be
more than just what they did and who
they are it's talking about memorable
and so i'm gonna take it back to the
third thor movie thor ragnarok what
anyone argues is the best of the series
and i'm talking about hella
this woman was not only a badass that
brought the entire
asgard team to its knees homegirl did it
in patent leather with
some fair style i mean that makeup was
on
point i enjoyed watching her wreak havoc
and calling ragnarok as much as i
watched enjoying any other part of the
mcu
she was funny she was deadly and she was
somebody that not only you wanted to
follow
in the back of your mind like maybe we
could kick it and have a beer with her
i'm just saying hella is not only the
best villain
she's the funnest to watch and by
extension for what about to hand off to
my tag team partner
we're going to talk about how both of
our people are birthed by one man who
should be the shadow villain
of all this certainly winning the
argument for horns thus fall and now we
go to
karamah and karama your complimentary
villain is
uh i'm sorry i think the biggest villain
in the mcu affecting the entire mcu
is loki this he is a trickster that's
been jacking up the mcu since he first
showed up in
thor number one he has tons of powers
illusion
manipulation he's a cold immunity frost
giant shape-shifter psychology he's got
a cloning jutsu
he lies he stays lying to everybody
which is what makes him
so dangerous he will sell anybody out at
any point in time
so you talking unexpected it's loki you
never know what he's gonna do
or when he's gonna do it and he is the
most unstable and yes
family odinson is jacked up
between hella and loki they have wreaked
more havoc through the entire mcu
at the hands of their father than any
other characters
not for just one movie but for loki
through the entire mcu
has been the strongest villain
god man caesar this might be my favorite
round that we've had thus far i mean you
have hella and loki and you're right
they have some
they share some lineage there but you're
countering team fandango that has two
incredible villains
a little more cerebral perhaps than you
might expect the classic villain to be
with
zemo and with killmonger and this is
gonna be a barber this one's coming down
to the wire and
if anybody wants to change their answer
we do have some other suggestions from
our chat room
um joseph says the us government is
actually the strongest
jedi forget the super villains the best
villain is the united nations
so there's the
there's a lot to pick from here uh braun
roberts says to be fair loki ended off
as a hero
it kind of but i'm i think he's squarely
he's in the round
we cannot go back i know you're going to
do the whole time travel part when they
were going back to get the throne
hey hey hey hey we're not there yet calm
down okay
like button for team tomatoes okay team
fandango your rebuttal is up
you got about 10 seconds of peace who
wants it first uh let me take it first
because first of all
loki's dead so i don't even know why
we're talking about loki um
and you know loki became a comic he
became a comic sidekick maybe the
avengers he's kind of creepy
but then they just kind of made him a
comic sidekick hella is
look i love kate blanchett but she is
the least memorable part of that movie
whenever they were with heller i was
like go back to the hulk and thor and
jeff goldblum and whatever the hell was
going on in that planet
that's what i wanted to see in that
movie and plus hella isn't in the first
two thor movies so
well you don't really care about it much
all right jay you're picking up the
slack
all right i like hella's patent leather
i'll say that but however
when it comes to killmonger it made
women across the world
identify with the villain there were
women all over the world were like uh
yeah maybe killmonger was right
think about it there are t-shirts that
still go around this day saying
killmonger was right
and again to be cerebral and to take
over one of the most powerful nations in
the world
that no one knew about until the end
speaks volumes all right
jay washington
no i'm talking to jackie i'm not talking
to you i'll go next
okay so i'm sorry loki is alive
at the end of end game loki is alive you
know i don't talk about the past he's
actually alive that's why there's a show
coming out so we said
so but that is the past loki's not in
the past loki is alive
the in terms of killmonger killmonger
was an amazing villain
but only in black panther he does not
affect the mcu and i'm sorry
women all over don't love killmonger why
because he killed every woman he put his
hands on in that movie
all right jacqueline uh pretty strong
opening there from caramel you're gonna
bring us home
in round number four well my girl
cameron was about to say the real one
that was right was nikita was right
played
by lupita nyong'o that is the message
you take we could do it better
without damaging black women while we do
that and let me go ahead and break it
down
who who just who who did nobody remember
that man didn't nobody remember what he
did and did nobody care
i'm talking about this woman killed the
asgardians
that's what we were getting to an
infinity war hella
hella done helen
zemo was the reason the avengers split
up zemo broke
up the avengers yes
and then a lot of hate ultimately in the
chat room is what i'm seeing i'm seeing
uh
lucy is firmly planted on team rotten
tomatoes anna christina comes in with a
great point she says odin is the best
villain because he's the worst parent so
if owner hadn't killed loki's dad stolen
him lied about it hitting the tesseract
in the basement
hitting the destroyer in the shed lied
about all of it including hello who
incidentally
he put in hell killed the folks who knew
about her and then redecorated
we probably wouldn't even have an mcu
but old nature
argument i'm agreeing with all right i
got the votes
got the votes in i'd like to applaud all
four of
our combatants here both teams foreign
um i think jay washington might have had
the most controversial statement when he
said let me speak for all women jay it
usually doesn't go well
hey jay i love you we're both single for
a reason my man
thank you thank you are in you voted
with your hearts you voted with your
thumbs like and love and ladies and
gentlemen
it's the mcu binge battle and it gives
me great pleasure to declare the winner
has not been named yet because we go to
round number five
takes round number four did i scare
y'all for a little bit a little bit yeah
everything you got to give we've been so
hard on you you get that one
you get that yeah you get that one i'm
not trying to give you a heart attack i
just want to make you all smell toast a
little bit so
move on to topic number five and it's
simple
and it's rotten tomatoes it's going to
be kicking us off
infinity war versus end game take that
however you want it
it's going to be oh my god he's still
pressing on his little toy that wasn't
me this time
jackie you killed the star yeah yeah i
got this
what right i shouldn't i don't want any
i don't want any like
somebody's throwing things in the
background trying to throw me off this
is like
this is deflate gate binge badge the
breaking
bad version i have in
to jay's house and i've seen the
infinity gauntlet up close and it does
make a really cool sound when you're
there
when you're virtual jay it kind of
sounds like you're having toilet issues
at your apartment
45 seconds i'm touching your toys this
is the round that will determine the
match
it's all yours i'm gonna go ahead and
say binge's versus endgame we've already
sort of made the case from this from
everything we've talked about
what moments have we been talking about
through this whole thing whether it be a
vengeance assemble whether it be on your
left whether it be captain america
dancing with
uh captain carter at the end of end game
because
end game is the movie that really brings
it home and i'll also tell you this
you could not watch the entire rest of
the mcu and you could watch
in game and you could have a moment a
complete movie
where it took you from the depths of
despair that five year break how many of
y'all had your heart stopped when you
saw that
and then they build you back up with
humor with love
with heart and they tie it off better
than the season finale of six feet under
this is one of the best culminations
in the history of cinema and there is no
way that the floor play to that
is going to in any way equate to what we
actually wanted to get to
which is the climax okay caravan you're
picking up the baton and running with it
45 seconds is all yours
okay eric said it in the pre-show
endgame made all the money
like the fans already chose this as the
best movie the
mcu infinity war is good but it's not a
complete movie
it isn't and we also knew at the end
that peter wasn't going to be really
dead we knew he was coming back
everything all of the moments including
tony's arc
when he dies the biggest moment of all
of the mcu
you cannot you cannot say that endgame
isn't the biggest you absolutely can
plus you guys argue that cap you know
we already talked about cap grabbing
mumu and mewmew which i love calling it
that
and saying avengers assemble all of
these things happened
in this movie not infinity war so i'm
sorry i gotta give it to endgame
all right uh yeah karen is right mumu is
the closest i get to pronouncing that
hammer right which is why i just call it
the hammer so
we go to team fandango uh pretty good
argument
for a pretty great closing to a
franchise or at least that chapter of it
so end game versus
infinity war who wants to go first with
quite a daunting task ahead of you
gentlemen
i got it it's infinity war because it's
done something no other movie has done
and will ever do it was the villain
story
the whole movie is the story of thanos
when the snap happens and at the end you
see him sitting in the garden smiling
everybody was like oh my god is that it
we keep calling it a two-part movie but
it's not
that was the end of that movie that
movie puts you on the edge of your seat
the whole way
to watch him kill his daughter and then
watch
thanos cry let's go to the beginning
when he break breaks loki's neck
when he kills uh heimdall and also
when he gives the hulk the foo flops on
that ship
avengers infinity the foofobs that's
from from the streets
listen infinity war did something that
nobody had ever seen done the villain
had the best part of the ark
the villain saw everything the villain
knew what to do
had the plan enacted the plan all you
had all of you split up the avengers
you had everybody blame the whole
destruction of the world
on star lord okay eric you're picking up
the baton from jay
and running us home avengers end game
made the most money because people
wanted to see how it ends
look avengers end game is the return of
the jedi of the mcu
avengers infinity war is the empire
strikes back of it
the pacing of that film is relentless
you are from one scene to the next to
the next to the next
the final battle is is an infinity war
is better than the final battle and end
game because you're in multiple places
you have wakanda you have the planet
with stark and
star-lord trying to fight thanos you
have thor off on his adventure with
rocket and group
all of it comes together you have this
awesome moment when they win
and then what do they do they kill
everyone you care about
it is a heartbreaking movie it is a
relentlessly paced movie if the safety
brothers directed an mcu movie it would
be infinity war
because the pacing is just fantastic
and you never want to stop turning you
never want to turn away because you will
miss something
end game has a lot of starts and stops
and some slow moments
infinity war has none of that it just
goes and goes and it doesn't stop
uh there's going to be a credit to both
teams because you all won me over with
both arguments like when
team rotten tomatoes was going in hard
on end game i'm like yeah of course it's
gonna be end game these guys are done
but then you all started talking about
infinity war
and the heart and the uh bold shall we
say
climax and ending of that movie they did
a pretty stirring day new mod to let
people talking for weeks and months so
it's a good argument and it's a great
binge battle so far
the winner is still up in the air and
that is going to be determined by you
the fan
once again vote with the thumbs up
button that's the like button if you
think rotten tomatoes has the better
argument but with the heart
the love button if you think that it is
team
fandango that is the rightful possessor
of
the infinity gauntlet which jay
washington apparently already stole so
we go back to
team rotten tomatoes you have about 20
seconds to wrap it up here
who wants to go first yeah
all right ready here we go let me just
go ahead and say this if you guys want
to say
infinity war is an amazing movie i don't
disagree it absolutely is an amazing
movie and it's probably one of the best
part ones in the history of cinema but
tell me something at the end of that
movie is it complete
no did it do something different
absolutely this movie paid off
22 movies perfectly the skill
the artistry this is simone biles in the
finals of the olympics
landing and getting perfect tens that is
the balance beam that they had to do
to make end game work infinity war could
fall off a cliff but if they don't stick
the landing with end game
it's all for nothing and if you don't
need any better example
rise of skywalker oh
jacqueline why are you going to go
you're pretty you're so petty
but eric you go ahead and handle that
one thing you're pushing up the argument
okay so telling the villain story that
has been done before
other movies have done that before doker
did it anime does it all the time that's
not new
engaged endgame starts by not knowing
what is going to happen we've
established that infinity war is a good
movie
but end game had to wrap it all up
otherwise
we don't have almost an end to phase
three i know it ends in spider-man i'm
just saying this had to happen
this literally had to exist and also
what are we quoting from infinity war
like all the quotes that we've talked
about in this entire battle
happened in end game and jay
what's street you want that says foofops
hey man look i'm from the south side of
chicago back in the year
starting okay well
infinity war is not a part one it is the
empire strikes back of the mcu
and infinity war gives us the best of
the avengers it gives us the best of
spider-man it gives us the best of
guardians of the galaxy
it gives us all of our favorite
characters all fighting together
end game you don't see the guardians you
don't see spider-man you don't get any
of them
until the end but you have all of the
best characters in black panther
all the best characters of all of your
favorite marvel movies
are all together on this journey in
infinity war it is really the movie that
we had all been waiting to see
all of these characters converging and
fighting and hanging out with each other
that's why
infinity war is far superior and yeah
you got end game is the return of the
jedi it's a good movie it
caps it all off but infinity war is
really the meat and potatoes of
the mcu's finale all right and if you go
off of that again you say what quotables
do
we have from infinity war the number one
quotable that made everybody keep
sitting on end is
you should have gone for the head that
one that quote within itself
you should have gone for the head
changed everything because you paid all
the time
it made you watch everybody that you
loved in these movies
be broken because they realized they
lost it showed you everybody just feel
despondent and despair
and again watching people again infinity
war gave you the saddest thing
i am groot when we found out he was
saying daddy to rocket
mr stark i don't i don't feel good
i love you 3 000. i love you three
thousand i love you 3
000. i love you 3 000 on your left
i mean like there's so many more quotes
this is all i have to say
i'm done i'm done i want the fish to
decide hopefully you decide right
what's better foreplay or the climax
what's better empire strikes back will
return to the jedi
all right jedi i can answer that
unbiased the answer is return of the
jedi because we win in the end and the
ewoks hang out so look
i'm gonna clear up one notion for y'all
right now okay
the best quote in either movie is
actually from infinity war because it's
when thor calls rocket raccoon sweet
rabbit it's the funniest
now with all that being said we're
tattling the votes right now and they're
coming in fast and furious get your last
chance to vote for team rotten tomatoes
or team fandango
i'm gonna read off a couple quotes
because y'all the chat room turned into
yogi bear because they are endlessly
quotable right now
uh joseph says uh end game relies on the
previous films but then anna says
infinity war has the best of both sides
of the fight and so
it really is that existential question
what do you prefer in movies do you like
it when it has
a really heartfelt emotional weave off
that is not complete or do you
like the happy ending where we all wrap
things up nice and tie it in a bow
that's really what we're coming down to
braun says infinity war doesn't conclude
on the ark it sets up it relies on
end game to pay them off so it's not
complete and
yajir says end game is the heart of the
entire mcu so many comments coming in
from you all on facebook i thank
everybody watching right now for
probably the most heated binge battle
that we've ever had and why not because
we're talking about
22 beloved films in the mcu and it all
comes down
to this because this is the moment i
remind everybody to check out
rottentomatoes.com
that is the hub where you can go find
all things binging you can check out all
the great ellipticals they have there
a lot of great articles on film on tv
shows everything you need in the world
of streaming is right there
at binge central oh and by the way the
winner of today's match
we have it you all voted with your
thumbs up y'all voted with your hearts
but at the end of the day
one team is beloved three thousand and
one
and that would be team rotten tomatoes
for the victory
y'all just didn't want to see karen or
blame jacqueline that's what it was
[Laughter]
team rotten tomatoes y'all get to go
first uh jacqueline start with you and
then we'll go to karama
incredible debating uh it was such a fun
spirited conversation that we had
uh jacqueline where can everybody uh
find you to check out more stuff that
you're working on right now
man i'm i don't need oxygen this was fun
but it was stressful
and y'all could find it
y'all gonna find me at that jaclyn
lydia literally on all platforms because
i am that girl
even on tick tock thank y'all this is
and um
let's uh let's have everybody give the
kids a quick uh streaming recommendation
real
uh real fast what what's something that
you're watching you think more people
need to check out jacqueline what do you
got
okay for a good streaming recommendation
i guess it's streaming uh you guys
should watch i may destroy you on hbo
it is by michelle uh michelle i'm gonna
say her name wrong
she did uh chewing gum on netflix and
she just did this new show which is
absolutely incredible
so check that out all right we go to
your co-winner there uh karen horn
camera you are now
two-and-oh in bench battles and it looks
like you're ready for another one right
now where can all the
check out more stuff you're doing um i'm
similar to jackie i'm just the blurred
girl everywhere t-h-e-b-l-e-r-d-g-u-r-l
um please check out the blurred girl
live on twitch every tuesday night
at 8 p.m eastern 5 p.m pacific my
uh guests actually i'll tease my guest
online later but it's a lot of fun i
just had daniel jose older
on my show um wow i was gonna
she took mine i was gonna say i may
destroy you also
uh teammates exactly
you know what here's one if you are
looking for a good horror movie that you
probably and you like zombies check out
kingdom
on netflix it's it is a korean period
period drama
but it is one of the best zombie series
i've ever seen
all right and i will also stump for one
of caramel's favorite properties avatar
the last airbender i can now pronounce
correctly yeah and have you watched it
i'm not finished with it yet so i will
well maybe maybe i can guess on the
twitch channel once i finish it that can
be my reward
so we'll we'll talk uh we go over
to team fandango eric j it was a tough
loss today but you all fought valiantly
and if you love infinity war this is
kind of your infinity war because maybe
there's some unfinished business
with team fandango and we'll have to
have you all return on a future episode
in the meantime eric where can all the
kids check out the stuff you're working
on
i think we just got snapped uh you can
watch
you can follow me uh uh just follow me
at fandango at
on twitter at eric with the k davis uh i
just want to say you know we're all
we're all friends uh we've all hung out
outside of this so it was awesome this
was a really great fun time
uh that we had uh and my streaming pick
mark i'm gonna go with a rarity
i'm gonna say you know what uh avengers
infinity war i'll all use in the
comments section
who voted for end game go back
he's better he's better because it is
the far superior moving
to avengers end game that's my binge
pick mark
i am not mad
i'm being really honest i would be
jealous
when this is all over to be able to do
this like in a bar oh my god this would
be great it would be amazing
well i i have done this in a bar with
jay many a time so
jay where can all the kids find you and
uh check out the stuff that you got
going on
uh i'm on twitter and instagram at mr j
washington that's m-r-j-a-y you should
know how to spell washington
um it's okay it's okay honey i still
love you i still love you i love y'all
too but i'm just saying i love you three
thousand i love you
shut your face shut your face
uh blurts in the hood every tuesday on
the blurs in the
youtube channel me and winston a
marshall uh we have five about hour 2 pm
pacific
p.m on the east coast and for my ben's
recommendation i'm gonna go anime and
i've been binge watching hunter x hunter
if you have not seen it every time you
think you know what the story is about
to be
they change it up and it keeps getting
better and better but this was a blast
we got to do this again
i just want a binge battle of nothing
infinity war versus in in-game that's it
we don't go about no other movies
we just go them too like each character
every question is based about them two
movies because whoever voted in game
you know what somebody hurts you in your
heart okay
we were streaming on because we kind of
did like our own adventures assemble we
were live on fandango
fandango all access movies.com the
rotten tomatoes youtube channel and the
rotten tomatoes facebook page we were
taking the votes from the facebook page
today but
across all those platforms we encourage
you to check out everything going on
rotten tomatoes and once again
rottentomatoes.com check out binge
central for all the latest going on
in the wild wacky wonderful world of
streaming i want to give a huge
shout out to our incredible team behind
the scenes making this all come together
making us look so pretty
and making the stream work making the
stream regenerate
just like weapons
if you want to check out something fun
streaming my new special dog stepfather
named after
that little nugget is currently on
amazon prime
thank you to caramel horn jacqueline
coley your winning team
and i'll say the runner-up team is eric
davis
and jay washington jay stay tuned we're
doing virtual stand up soon so get your
set ready
in the meantime i'll be doing some of
these shows anyway tuning in on behalf
of everyone rotten tomatoes
we'll see you soon
you